it's an overcast chilly afternoon
here in the bronx but it's opening day
so it feels like the sun is actually
shining
and check that out there are going to be
fans in the stands to watch the yankees
play for the first time since the
postseason
in 2019. oh yeah it is time for baseball
and a lot expected of the guy who's
starting for the yankees today garrett
cole yeah he is a monster on the mound
and just what yankee fans need and want
and he has
come as advertised as you see last
season just in the 12 starts but
very good across the board simeon is
ready
garrett cole takes a breath he is ready
crowd into it the 1-0 grounded left side
torres one down
and the one two did he go
yes he did bigio down on strikes
beshet a yankee killer so far early in
his career and cole going hard
grounded to le mayhew a one two three
inning for garrett cole and the yankees
dungeon riou turned 34
in march during spring training he went
five and two a year ago for the blue
chase
he's truly one of the premier pitchers
in all of baseball the mayhew struck out
just
21 times in 216 plate appearances
a season ago the jams lemay he went a
one hopper down to first played by
vladimir guerrero jr
judge steps in for the yankees 3-2 on
the way and a late swing and a miss
there on a 91 mile an hour fastball and
ryu
rings him up you know so much of hitting
is timing and you can see how late
judge is it's 91 miles an hour so two
down here in the bottom of the first and
here's aaron hicks they're trying to get
on the same page right now here comes
the 2-2 to hicks swing and a miss
got him with a fastball same as he did
to judge
oscar hernandez will lead it off for the
blue jays in the second
2-2 swinging a ground ball in the hole
it's short
and it scoots through the shortstop
that'll bring up vladimir guerrero jr
and he starts producing like everybody
thought he would when he was coming up
through the miners and he swings
and hits a screamer into center field on
the first pitch he sees from
cole a rocket right back up the middle
on a fastball
up to second on the play goes hernandez
and the blue jays got something cooking
here in the top of the second no score
in the game
first and second with nobody out for
lourdes goriel
two on nobody out one-one and a swing
and a base hit into center field
for goriel and tay oscar hernandez will
round third and come into score and the
blue jays string together
three consecutive hits to take a one to
nothing lead
slider that stays on the inner half it
didn't break away it stayed on the inner
half but curio goes right back up the
middle
no problem at all forte oscar to come in
the score and the blue jays are on the
board
and there are two ways here's a catcher
danny jansen
3-2 stride three johnson down looking
strikeout number three for garrett
jewelry and that will bring up gary
sanchez
well the eyes are upon gary sanchez
there's no question about
it sanchez hits one deep to left field
going back guriel looking up
sia a two-run home run for sanchez
and the yankees lead two to one oh that
gary is scary he is a two-run homerun
can you imagine how great he feels
boy in a year after he hit 147 his first
at batter the next year and he does this
now here's the 2-2 breaking ball strike
three
oh what a great breaking ball nose to
toes
now chew down and here is bo buchet
strike three one two three inning five
strikeouts in three innings for garrett
cole
and oscar hernandez will lead off
strike three hernandez down looking
three straight strikeouts
for garrett cole and five of the last
six out strikeouts
goriel singled in the run his first time
as a right-hand hitter
swinging a miss strikeout number seven
for garrett cole
man hicks is a good hitter he's a switch
hitter batting right-handed against ryu
3-2 swing and a miss on a fastball up
above the belt hicks down on strikes one
down
two down to the base is empty for gleber
torres one-two pitch is there
torres called out on strikes and hungen
ryu
has set down seven in a row bruce up to
second on the play with two down now the
concern is you got two men on you got to
go back to the top of the order for dj
lemayo
2-1 yankees bottom five two on two out
and a change-up
grounded to the right side diving stop
simeon on to first
in time to get him a terrific play by
marcus simeon to retire d.j lemayhew and
the yankees
in the bottom of the fifth leaving a
couple of men on yankees have a 2-1 lead
as we hit the top
of the sixth nearest bo bachette
pitch half swing at a slider he struck
out on a pitch
that was in the left hand hit his
batter's box strikeout number eight
for garrett cole so here's hernandez now
a base hit and a strikeout
and he got a pitch over the heart of the
plate and he
crushed it hernandez with a monster home
run to tie
the game at two you talk about a no
doubter
tay oscar knew it cole knew it and this
game is tied
missed outside as guerrero walks for the
second
time and aaron boone makes the slow walk
to the mount he's going to signal to the
bullpen that's going to do it for
garrett cole
well you know this feeling david he was
not very pleased the way his afternoon
just ended left hand please
use your left and out of the blue jay
bullpen
now to work the bottom of the seventh
and a 2-2 tie get a familiar face a guy
in his second stint with the blue jays
buck in david phelps
the bases are loaded for aaron judge
phelps needs a ground ball right at
somebody
the 2-1 a swinging a ground ball to
third bishio to second one
onto first for the double play
somehow phelps and the blue jays get out
of it
the winning run at first base here comes
mike talkman out of the dugout
and he will run for sanchez here's jay
bruce his first game is a yankee
runner goes pitches high throw to second
hits a stolen base for topman and now
the winning run is in scoring position
the 3-2
and he got him got him to chase down and
away for the first down
well here's clint frazier the yankees
looking for a base hit to score the
winning run
runner goes and the ball mishandled by
johnson
and now talkman is just 90 feet away
from winning the game
runners at first and third with one on
here is dj and brett gardner's running
for clint frazier at first
first pitch to the mayhew a ground ball
to third nation coming home the tag
and they got him tuckman out of the
played as
bishop throws him out so judge can
deliver the verdict here on an
opening day in the bronx he has a chance
to win this
romano sets here comes fastball and he
got him swinging
what a job by jordan romano so jonathan
davis great speed for the blue jays out
at second base
as we go to extra innings and randall
griching to lead it off
as bridgic slashes the ball to right
field judge back and it's over his head
and now it bounces back by him towards
the infield
davis is in to score grinchik has hit
second with an rbi double
and the blue jays have taken the lead
jonathan davis with his speed scores
easily the blue jays take the lead here
in the 10th
so that'll leave it up the gleber torres
gleber is one for three with a walk he
scored a run
he's got his side from janssen one ball
two strikes
fastball and he got him swing and a miss
by torres
meriwether gets the save and the blue
jays
win on opening day in the bronx by a
score of three to two